Joe Biden is not known for his
consistency over the years Joe has
changed his views on just about every
issue Under the Sun from crime to
abortion to foreign policy to marriage
to pretty much everything else
unprincipled politicians such as Joe
Biden sometimes refer to this kind of
flip-flopping as evolving
and now it seems Joe Biden has evolved
into a Puerto Rican I was sort of raised
in the Puerto Rican community at home
politically and so we and we came here
for a long time both for business and
pleasures
Richard Levine is a woman
Elizabeth Warren is an Indian
Joe Biden is a Puerto Rican I don't
think
that people believe that Joe Biden is a
Puerto Rican
I don't think
I don't think people believe Joe Biden
period
I think Joe Biden
is not persuasive and I think the reason
that he and and all the other libs are
not really persuasive is because they
keep being proven wrong
it's the fool me one shame on you fool
me twice shame on me or as George W bush
put it fool me twice the point is you're
not going to fool me again and and with
the lips it's fool me three times fool
me four times fool me five times
covid certainly accelerated that Trend
and so it's just
it's not persuasive especially when you
compare Biden and the Democrats with the
political alternative
you want to talk about persuasive you
want to talk about in charge Ron
DeSantis down there in Florida in uh the
wake of this horrible hurricane that
destroyed so much of Florida killed a
lot of people destroyed a lot of
property at CNN is using this as an
opportunity to really Grill the governor
and make it seem like he's not competent
that this is somehow his fault which of
course is absurd listen to how Ron
DeSantis knocks the CNN reporter down
why do you stand behind Lee County's
decision to not have that mandatory
evacuation until the day before the
storm well did you where was your
industry stationed when the storm hit
were you guys in Lee County no you were
in Tampa so that's you know they were
following the weather track and they had
to make decisions based on that but you
know 72 hours they weren't even in the
cone 48 hours they were on the periphery
so you got to make the decisions the
best you can I will say uh you know they
delivered the message to people they had
shelters open you know everybody had
adequate opportunity to at least get to
a shelter within the county but you know
a lot of the residents did not did not
want to do that I think for probably for
various reasons some people just don't
want to leave their home period their
island people whatever but I think part
of it was so much attention was paid to
Tampa that I think a lot of them
probably thought that they wouldn't get
the worst of it so you know they um but
they did it and I think it's uh it's
easy to second-guess them but they were
ready for the whole time and and made
that call when when there was
justifiable to do so by the way this
goes on for about another minute and
DeSantis goes he's just citing facts
he's citing hour-by-hour weather trends
he's pointing out that CNN also thought
that the storm was going to move in a
particular way and then after the storm
shifted then Florida shifted resources
down and so you just you leave that
conversation with the impression
this guy knows what he's doing
okay if they had asked Joe Biden that
question what would he have done he
would have started drooling he would
have started talking about Corn Pop in
the Delaware public pool he would it's
it's not you can't even compare the two
it's not that that Joe Biden might not
have been able to cite all of those
facts Joe Biden wouldn't have known what
state he was in and so when people are
comparing Republican leadership right
now to Democrat leadership it doesn't
take a a political nerd you know someone
following all the trends to see oh the
Republicans basically have their act
together the Democrats have no idea
what's going on you can see this there
was a video that went viral yesterday of
a guy who I don't think he's a political
consultant you know I don't think that
this is a guy who's you know constantly
keeping up refreshing the page on Real
Clear Politics every day he's a regular
Florida Citizen who says look I'm a
Democrat I've always considered myself a
Democrat but DeSantis seems so competent
I'm voting for that guy
y'all but it's here in Arcadia so y'all
know who we vote for
him
and I'm a Democrat yeah
there's just a real persuasive aspect to
competence
to just a basic degree of confidence we
tend to think of Politics as this
ideological struggle between the
leftists and the conservatives and the
marxists and the fascists and the
desists and that but for a lot of people
politics comes down to hey are you going
to show up can you just like show up
when bad stuff happens and try to make
it better hey can you reduce crime in my
neighborhood hey can you keep the
economy kind of going along hey can you
fill my potholes fill my potholes
is a really important political
tactic okay fill my potholes goes a long
long way
and and DeSantis is doing it he's doing
it on every single level you even heard
In that clip DeSantis he said you know
there are misleading narratives you guys
are you guys are pushing misleading
narratives and I've noticed that Ron
DeSantis I don't know if it was in that
specific level it was certainly in the
CNN interview and he keeps coming back
to this misleading narratives why
because misleading narratives is the Ron
DeSantis version of fake news right
Donald Trump says you're fake news Ron
DeSantis is saying the exact same thing
but he uses a synonym because he doesn't
want to just be seen as a copycat of
trump he wants he adopts a lot of
Trump's uh characteristics and habits he
uses the Trump hands the sort of like
New York Italian hands really but he
uses the Trump hands he uses some of the
Trump diction and and Cadence but he
changes it he makes it his own and that
I think that competence goes a long way
especially if DeSantis does choose to
run
in 2024
presidents tend to be the opposite of
their predecessors
right you think of
George W bush go all the way back to
George W bush Bill Clinton is marked by
this kind of liberal skeezy you know
completely irreligious immoral White
House full of Scandal and then George W
Bush whatever you think of the guy he's
a pretty upright man born-again
Christian you know there's there's no no
sex scandals coming out of the George W
bush White House then after Bush what do
we get we get Barack Obama so the bushes
old white establishment
vaguely conservative Barack Obama young
fresh newcomer leftist first black
president then what do you get after
Obama after Obama who's this young fresh
radical we're gonna fundamentally
transform America we hate the old
America Obama's wife says the first time
I was ever proud of my country was when
it elected my husband what happens you
get Donald Trump who says now we're
bringing back the old America make
America great again right Donald Trump
this older guy kind of more old school
right wing style then after Trump who
was relatively pretty effective actually
even in just one term in office even
with the Deep State trying to undermine
him what do you get you get and this guy
who's a total populist bull in a china
shop upending The Establishment what do
you get you get the most establishment
boring guy in the entire world Joe Biden
so what comes after Biden maybe you get
Trump again
but DeSantis is putting himself in a
position where he could be
a good alternative there's no question
about it the rest of the show is
continuing now you do not want to miss
it
if you are not a member click the link
in the description and join us we have a
great interview coming up
it's with Michael schellenberger Michael
schellenberger is a really really
important voice
on environmental issues and Michael
schellenberger is is shedding some light
on what I think are not only the
ludicrous but downright offensive
Democrat claims about hurricane Ian and
and all the destruction down in Florida
which they they blame on global warming
and those mean old conservatives who
don't want to recycle or whatever Drive
Teslas
and uh Schellenberg brings a little bit
of science to that so we will get to him
in just one second see you over at the
member block
[Music]
[Music]